all right so then any standard
deviations which I will catch up with
and I want you to help me remember
dz8 DUI just share with you um what does
the let DV a mean to yet to be different
to stray from it's like he's he's way
everyone is and you deviate you go
somewhere else right so I always sort of
funny when you put one standard in front
of deviation it's kind of a bit of an
oxymoron okay
the idea is have a look at each of these
right do you remember we said the main
for all of these is to say by the way
we're a symbol for the mean does anyone
remember what was it was excellent are a
line above it which is why we call it
like you read it as X bar so if you see
that and I say X bar or whatever that's
what I'm referring to
um X bar the mean is just 12 in all of
these papers what standard deviation is
is is a measure of okay well if this is
the mean how far do most of these people
go away from that how far do they
deviate from the mean what would you
predict is the standard deviation of
this set of school it'll be zero because
they don't deviate at all I'm here
you're gonna get a bigger standard
deviation will I'll show you in
calculate in a minute and then here what
would you expect you'd have it even even
larger right so it's you know how we
said this is in the accessible measures
of spread this is a measure of how far
spread out have you put these monthly
thing so what are your calculator and
I've got this up here so you can see
because we do it certainly frequently
maybe you've forgotten how to do this
and you may want to drop down on some of
these steps for Stan abusers
okay so that's the first step so with
your calculator are normal you need to
press the mode button
don't press shift mode just same mode
and you can see there are three modes
there's computation statistics and then
this verification you can play with that
whatever for a while if you look what
we're usually in computation mode which
is one press two and we'll change it to
staff it would depend on if you've got a
plus two or something else so I'm okay
now
just just so that you're aware I'm gonna
do a lot of these steps so just keep the
discussion to immune because I don't
want you to be like two or three steps
behind you like I've no idea what's
happening you've got a whole bunch
options okay the only one we're really
gonna be interested in is this first one
1-var stands for one variable okay
so we'll have a look at that we'll press
1 and then this is what happens on my
screen so what you're telling what this
is telling you is here are uh this is
whichever score like it's counting the
number of scores you put in and X is
what's the score okay so for instance I
could say 12 and then if I hit equals
that's my first school and then I can go
12 again and then 12 again and 12 again
now I have four scores and they're all
12 now how do we work out some things to
do with this well if you can see down
here up above the number one you can see
it's a step above that so we're in stat
there now so if I say shift one right
you can see I've got all of these
different options here I'm gonna go wait
it's not
did you just tuck the same you've got
what I'm going for use cuz I had
something different no I need to work
out what's the difference because I
didn't have that that's okay the
difference between what we've done okay
um I don't know exactly why you still
see that where am I going
I'll have to sell out what was the
difference because they should be more
options I'll show you them in a second
provided I can replicate it maybe I
screwed up your calculator Note 2 if you
get a ship 1 and I'll find out if use
your calculator look like mine before
I'll try and work out what's going on
but this is what you're supposed to see
oh look I did it again as someone who's
got felt you know more options
oh oh wait maybe that's it
I think I know what I've done I think
yeah there we go eat it up sorry you see
I do this in between the two and have to
remind myself
you remember that screen I showed you
before this one right so you're in this
mode when you're putting scores in okay
when you're putting scores in once
you've got all the scores that you want
what you actually want to do is on is
clear the screen okay I'm pretty sure
that's the difference so I'm going to
keep on and even though it's clear now
the data is still there
okay it's just sort of tucked behind now
I'm going to press shift one if I wanted
to look back at the data just input I
would say to Madonna but what I want is
on something different I'm gonna press
fall for variable okay now I got to beat
me now did it make sense oh we all the
same page
I press on to clear it I think if you
press they see I guess it detected yes I
see so same yeah so so punchy numbers
here once you've punched your four
scores in then clear it and then you can
press shift one that okay I might write
that down so step one is get into stats
mode you've got to get into stats
step two is enter your data and then
this is apparently really important you
better clean the screen clear the screen
and then shift 1 we get us to these
options
KC will do one will do it's important we
do it and it just it was just worked
your calculator is different okay so
let's just have a quick look at this
okay the three that we're interested in
are one two and three I'll talk about
for later on one and what does that mean
what do you think that means let's just
press on find out one equals what do you
think it means it's how many schools I
have okay so and is how many scores
you've got if you go back to shift one
shift one principal for variable what's
- so that's the mean the last thing we
want is this guy here that's standard
deviation so I'm actually gonna write
that down five it looks like that's
that's the thing I want let's press it
three and hit OK wait is that what we
expected it is because this is where all
of the scores are the same so you've got
no standard deviation